[Music]
we believe the FISA warrant process was
abused and the reason we want a special
counsel is I think crimes may have been
committed I want somebody to look at how
the FBI FISA warrant application was
handled just like mother's looking at
the Trump campaign the Inspector General
is independent he just needs some help
we'll give him the tools to do it
because they cannot be counted on to
investigate themselves I mean it's kind
of common sense the FBI and the
Department of Justice were corrupt in my
view and the entire FISA warrant
application process was abused
well hours after that interview here on
special report and the call for a
special counsel some breaking news first
uncovered by Molly Hemingway at the
Federalist about an interesting set of
text messages between some figures that
we've been following for some time July
2016 the FBI opens its Russia
investigation and text messages indicate
the FBI agent Peter struck an FBI lawyer
Lisa page they were having an affair
they were talking about a relationship
Peter struck had with a federal judge
judge Contreras and in this it ends up
that this is the federal judge who would
later handle the prosecution of the
former national security adviser Mike
Flynn and it also turns out he sits on
the secret FISA Surveillance Court now
the text message lisa page rudy is on
the Fiske did you know that that's the
FISA Court I did we talked about it
before and after I need to get together
with him he said he's gotten a month or
two ago he gotten on a month or two ago
at a graduation party we were both were
at she not sure who she is brought up a
good point about being circumspect and
talking to him in terms of not placing
him into a situation where he'd have to
recuse himself
I can't imagine either one of you could
talk about anything in detail meaningful
enough to warrant recusal was struck
really Rudy I'm in charge of espionage
for the FBI and the Espionage FISA comes
before him what should he do given his
friend oversees them standards for
recusal are quite high I just don't
think this poses an actual conflict
struck says he's super thoughtful and
rigorous about ethics and conflicts am
not sure who em is suggested the social
setting with others would probably be
better than a one-on-one meeting I'm
sorry I'm just going to have to invite
you to that cocktail party have to come
up with some other work plead for people
to cover for action at least a page why
more 6:00 is a perfectly fine dinner
party we don't know where that goes but
it raises all kinds of questions about
what they were trying to do with a FISA
judge and and motives behind all of this
let's bring in our panel byron york
chief political correspondent of the
washington examiner david cantonese
senior politics writer for the US News &
World Report and Jason Reilly Wall
Street Journal columnist and senior
fellow at the Manhattan Institute Byron
your take on all this and how big a deal
are not big a deal it is well it could
be a big deal one of the mysterious
events of this whole affair was when
Michael Flynn pled guilty in November of
30 last year the original judge who
accepted that guilty plea a few days
later is off the case
we don't know if he removed himself or
if he was removed but we don't know
that's the judge we're talking about
here also they should also point out the
Peter struck is the FBI agent who
interviews Michael Flynn and everything
concerning Peter struck is a big deal
because of his centrality in the whole
Trump Russia affair he is the guy who
interviewed Flynn and Contreras the
judge was on the FISA Court we all heard
a lot about the FISA Court which
repeatedly accepted or approved a search
warrant for Carter page so wondering
what's going on there and the other big
thing one last big thing is the Justice
Department apparently turned over these
texts a few months ago but that the
parts we're talking about were redacted
and some of the staffers went back to
the Justice Department and saw a less
redacted version of that and now we have
it so the question is what was up with
the Justice Department originally yeah
you have the judge who accepted Flynn's
guilty plea apparently had a personal
relationship with the FBI agents that
interrogated him moreover from these
text messages it looks like those agents
wanted to exploit that relationship in
the
case what it tells me Brett ultimately
these text messages is that you not only
had people at the FBI who were opposed
to a trump presidency you had people at
the FBI who are actively plotting
against a trump presidency and that
seems to cross the line so we don't know
what we don't know we've said that with
the Muller investigation as well but
listening to senators Grassley and
Graham last night they know more than
they are saying with these lists of
questions in this letter calling for a
special counsel you add this to what the
concerns are that they list and it seems
like maybe it's more likely that one
comes about it could but I think in
going back and looking at this I think
the most troubling part was your point
that they didn't share at all with
Congress there was there is a motive to
to hide it and I think that is always
the problem with with this cover-up now
to be fair of the larger molar
investigation this mr. Strock was
removed he did take him off the
investigation we also don't know if this
has anything to do with the material
problem here isn't that or the material
charge that Michael Flynn lied right
that that's that is the essence of this
case that he lied to FBI officers about
meetings with foreign officials hears we
don't know if that changes if this has
anything to do with that central charge
that's why he's in hot water but had he
known Michael Flynn that is that the guy
that was investigating him and asking
him the questions was conspiring and had
this political bias and the judge that
he said I plead guilty to had the
relationship with the guy who asked him
the questions would he have pled guilty
good question I don't I don't know if he
would have pled guilty I think that's
what that's a question for Michael
Flores it turned out there was another
question here Andrew McCabe we're
waiting any minute on a decision whether
the administration and specifically Jeff
Sessions the attorney general will fire
him hours before he's scheduled to
retire to get his pension thoughts on
that as we get a decision one way or
another before Sunday well it shouldn't
be ticking down on the clock like this
it doesn't make a lot of sense but it it
is the case apparently that the FBI's
office of Professional Responsibility
has recommended
taking action against mccabe this is not
just this is not the present Trump on
his head this is actually the FBI's
office of Professional Responsibility
and we do have an inspector general's
report coming pretty soon about the
FBI's handling of the Hillary Clinton
email investigation which obviously has
something in it if it's triggering all
of this call for special counsel exactly
and all of these people who were
involved we're talking about with Trump
Russia they were also involved in the
Clinton email investable and if they
don't move against if this Attorney
General Jeff Sessions as call if he
doesn't move against McCabe ticking down
to Sunday what our president from tweets
like Monday morning about his attorney
general we know he's already frustrated
with the Jeff Sessions let me play this
sound bite that I thought was
fascinating from Jonathan Turley last
night with Martha about mccabe and this
whether he's going to get fired ahead of
this retirement or not the real strange
thing about all this is that mccabe so
far has been worried more about pensions
than prison that's not the choice that
was given by to Michael Flynn Michael
Flynn if you recall was charged with
false statements even though commis
investigators reportedly believed that
Flynn didn't intend to mislead them
that's not apparently the conclusion of
the inspector general with regard to
McCabe I think he's right the these law
enforcement officials are not above the
law if you are I lied to an FBI
investigator there would be consequences
if McCabe lied there should be constable
how would how would mccabe treat us if
we lied to his agency well we're going
to follow it and so far nothing no word
on anything whether there's moves in the
administration we've got you covered
here